this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
Christian rapper flames sued Katy Perry
claiming that this song copied this song
a jury agreed and awarded him 2.8
million dollars but when a jury found
that the writers of Katy Perry's 2013
hit Dark Horse featuring Juicy J had
copied part of a 2008 song called joyful
noise by Christian rapper flame it set
off a major firework in the music
industry the jury ordered Perry and the
other riders to pay almost 2.8 million
dollars to flame for copying a small
part of his song
however after Perry's lawyers filed a
motion to overturn the verdict the trial
court decided it was time to hear it
roar see what I did there in March the
court threw out the jury's verdict
dismissing the case and believe it or
not Katy Perry was saved by none other
than Led Zepplin I am not kidding that
is actually what happened to understand
how this case wound up being so
controversial we have to take a dive
into federal copyright law and music
theory so strap in
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because I'm just a California
girl now now no more Katy Perry
references I'm sorry the dispute over
Dark Horse is not about the songs
themselves but about a short eight note
melody that flame believes that Dark
Horse writers copied from his song
joyful noise and it's true they both
have a similar musical component called
an ostinato and that's actually sort of
unusual for a copyright case see usually
in lawsuits like this you're comparing
the entire song for example George
Harrison was successfully sued by the
chiffons over his song My Sweet Lord
which was suspiciously similar to the
chiffons he's so fine
[Music]
he's so bad
here the songs are pretty different but
the songs at issue do have a similar
component their austin autos in austin
auto is a short melody or pattern like
an arpeggio that is constantly repeated
throughout the song usually in the same
part of the same pitch
however proving copyright infringement
in music is complex because there are
only a limited number of notes and
arrangements available to composers and
musicians if you listen to the radio for
30 minutes today for example you will
hear common themes repeated in many
songs and it's for this reason that the
individual elements of a song simply are
not protected by copyright and that's
why music industry professionals were
alarmed by the parry verdict for 2.8
million dollars many songs use the same
musical building blocks if one musician
can copyright the underlying structure
it would radically change the musical
landscape and allow for musical
monopolies but I'm not an expert in
music theory if only I had some expert I
could turn to to explain the musical
concepts at issue wait a minute I've got
an idea
[Music]
it appears that I have been summoned so
joyful noise in Dark Horse both employ
similar ostinatos an ostinato is a
simple repeated melodic fragment on top
of which a songwriter a composer might
write more prominent melodies so it's
kind of like the backbone of a
composition both songs ostinatos are
very similar as the defense pointed out
they both are in minor keys they both
have the same rhythm of eight evenly
spaced quarter notes they both start in
a third note or scale degree of the
minor scale repeat that note four times
then descend down to the second note of
the minor scale and repeat that note
twice after this Dark Horse's ostinato
descends the first scale degree and then
below to the fifth scale degree and
joyful noises ostinato actually changes
every other time the first time it
resolves to the first scale degree and
the second time you hear it resolves
down to the sixth
scale degree so technically they're
different that they are very similar in
the fact that they both are ostinatos
they're in minor keys they have the same
rhythm and they both start the same way
with the same scale degrees now the
problem that I have with this is that
these elements aren't remotely unique to
joyful noise or darkhorse
you can find any combination of these
elements in our shared musical tradition
quite easily for example each quarter
note ostinatos like Pachelbel's Canon in
D or for example minor key ostinatos
that start on the third degree and
descend down to the first degree like
carol of the bells or of course the
baseline to fancy by Iggy Azalea or you
can get specific like eighth note
melodies in minor keys that start on the
3rd scale degree repeat 4 times and then
descend down to the 2nd scale degree and
then repeat again you can find that in
Bach's violin sonata and F minor the
Adagio movement I've taken individually
these points of similarity are banal
they represent really fundamental
building blocks of music even that
specific sequence of notes of the third
degree going to the second degree
thanks Adam really appreciate it and I
promise only to summon you if it's a
musical emergency definitely check out
Adams channel if you have any interest
in music theory or bass guitar in
general it's amazing and as Adam points
out the eighth note ostinato in dark
horse sounds a lot like the ostinato in
joyful noise but that's not the end of
the analysis there are lots of different
ostinatos that sound similar to that
just because something sounds similar
doesn't necessarily mean that there was
copyright infringement
the ostinatos at issue sound like a
whole bunch of other songs are all of
these songs infringing on each other to
understand the answer to that question
we have to take a deeper dive into the
songs themselves and into copyright law
to prove a claim of copyright
infringement the copyright owner has to
prove two elements first the person has
to own a valid copyright and two they
have to show that the protectable
portions of the copyrighted work have
been infringed and infringement is
usually defined as unlawful
copying now while that sounds like a
clear test it's really just the tip of
the iceberg to prove unlawful copying
you have to show that a person actually
copied the work at issue which usually
requires proving access and it also
requires proving substantial similarity
which is that the things that were
copied give rise to the standard that we
say the it was enough copying to
constitute copyright infringement now
access and actual copying are really
important because technically
independent creation is a defense to
copyright infringement if you happen to
come up with the exact same form of art
technically if you say we're on an
uninhabited island in the South Pacific
when you created this thing well then
there was no way for you to who have
copied someone else so not only does
something have to be substantially
similar in terms of what is created but
you also have to prove that someone had
access to the thing that was copied and
that they actually did do the copying
itself and most copyright cases direct
evidence isn't available so that's why
creators rarely have proof that the
defendant actually listened to a song or
directly pilfered parts of it for their
own use instead plaintiffs rely often on
circumstantial evidence to make their
case now that's just to prove that
copying of some form existed but what
about the test for substantial
similarity to prove that the things that
were copied were copied in a way that
gives rise to copyright infringement
well in determining whether two works
are substantially similar the courts use
a two-part analysis an objective
extrinsic test and a subjective
intrinsic test now the subjective
intrinsic test is almost always a
question for the jury it's something a
court can't decide itself it asks what a
normal person with no background in
musicology or in whatever kind of art is
at issue here would they feel the the
two works are similar enough that the
copying is actionable but the extrinsic
test considers whether two works share a
similarity of ideas an expression as
measured by external objective criteria
the extrinsic test requires analytical
dissection of a work and expert
testimony and that dissection means that
the court will break down the works into
their constituent parts and compare
their elements this is an analysis that
the court the judge in this particular
case
can do its objective it's based on the
the face of the works themselves and
when a court conducts this analysis it's
looking only at the protected elements
of a copyrighted work it's always
essential to distinguish between the
protected and unprotected material for
example if something is in the public
domain you can use it and you can make a
new work but you only get protection
over the new protected elements not the
unprotected things that are in the
public domain and this is where flame
ran into trouble with the court he was
unable to show that that one brief
section of joyful noise was sufficiently
original in its protectable
copyrightable parts and not every part
of flame song was copyrightable for a
creative work to be entitled to
copyright protection it must be an
original work of authorship and when the
supreme court defined originality it set
a pretty low bar a work is original if
it is independently created in
possessing at least some minimal degree
of creativity and as I mentioned before
this is a really interesting case
because usually you're dealing with the
whole song or the whole book or the
whole movie here we're not talking about
both songs in their entirety but merely
constituent parts and some musical
elements are not protectable at all such
as a chord progression or a recurring
vocal phrase or a syncopated rhythm to
name just a few common elements of songs
as one court remarked these are building
blocks which belong to the public domain
and cannot be appropriated by any
particular author because in western
music there's only so much stuff you can
do within the key of a song musical
emergency you see in western music we
have this thing called in tonality where
all the notes of the scale have a
specific function to play they want to
do certain things so if you're writing a
song using tonality which chances are if
you're writing a pop song it's gonna be
tonal there are a very limited number of
ways each note can plausibly resolve to
the next any pleasing manner and if
you're writing a pop song you want it to
be pleasing in theory so well yeah the
two ostinatos are similar musically that
doesn't mean a whole lot yeah and what's
really interesting here is that we're
dealing with a small sub component of a
song the ostinato by way of analogy
imagine
have a copyright infringement case with
two novels the whole work itself would
be the novel that novel is broken up
into subcomponents either sentences or
words and those words themselves are
broken up into letters I'm not aware of
any particular copyright case that
allows you to copyright an individual
word it's just it's too small but you
can string a whole bunch of letters
together to form words and then string a
whole bunch of words together to form an
entire novel and at some point it has
the creativity necessary to be
copyrightable and a song is the same way
if you start with the whole song that is
made up of individual components often
musical phrases or maybe it's a drum
line versus the melody and the the vocal
melody and the words and those things
are made up often of individual notes
just like letters make up an individual
word and I suppose it could be
theoretically possible to have a very
small number of notes to form a
copyrightable work but you would imagine
it would be very very difficult to have
an eighth note musical phrase become a
copyrightable thing itself and in fact
the Ninth Circuit has found that a four
note melody is not copyrightable here
we're dealing with eighth notes and
obviously there's a spectrum at some
point you go into the hundreds or
thousands of notes and that becomes an
entire song itself and here although the
jury heard extensive testimony about the
similarities between joyful noise and
dark horse the plaintiff simply couldn't
prove that the eighth note ostinato was
original enough to receive copyright
protection expressions that are standard
stock or common to a particular subject
matter or medium are not protectable
under copyright law is what the judge
found now the plaintiffs expert
musicologist identified five distinct
elements that he thought were
protectable as they were used by joyful
noise in the plaintiffs brief they
identified even more elements a total of
nine that they thought deserved
copyright protection and in response
katy perry and the other defendants
argued that it didn't matter whether
there were three or five or nine
elements since none of them were
protectable on their own and in a win
for Adam Neely the court also referred
to other songs that featured very very
similar Austin
like merrily we roll along in jolly old
st. Nicholas to explain that the
particular ostinato was not
copyrightable but the court didn't stop
there because there are circumstances
where you can string together a series
of unprotectable elements to form a
larger protectable thing i mean that is
what a novel is every individual word is
not copyrightable but if you string
enough of them together then that does
eventually become copyrightable so in
theory flame could have proven
infringement of the ostinato if he was
able to show that the combination of
unprotectable elements are original
enough in the way that they are arranged
and you can combine non-copyright of all
things together to get protection but
when you do that you generally get
what's called thin copyright protection
if the underlying things themselves are
not copyrightable then the only thing
that you get copyright over is the
actual arrangement itself and when you
are dealing with thin copyright
protection and you claim that someone
has infringed the copyright on your
selection then generally those two
things have to be virtually identical or
there is no copyright infringement and
as the court found it is undisputed in
this case even viewing the evidence in
the light most favorable to the
plaintiffs that the signature elements
of the eight-note ostinato and joyful
noise is not a particularly unique or
rare combination even in its deployment
as an ostinato prior compositions
including prior works composed by the
parties as well as what all agree is a
separate non-infringing ostinato and
darkhorse all contains similar elements
since the sole musical phrase that flame
claimed was infringement was not a
protectable expression the extrinsic
test was not satisfied and therefore
flames claimed failed as a matter of law
oh god that was hard to say now it's
theoretically possible to copyright a
musical phrase but it would need to be
really really special it is as it should
be really hard to copyright
subcomponents of songs because lots of
people use the exact same thing over and
over again we have a musical library
that is inherent to Western music
imagine if someone tried to copyright
this drum rhythm or if someone tried to
copyright this lick
[Music]
sorry man
false alarm sorry about that now flames
expert musicologist pointed to nine
elements that he claimed when taken
together made an otherwise non
copyrightable set of notes copyrightable
he pointed to a melody built in the
minor mode a phrase length of eight
notes a pitch sequence beginning with
three three three three two two a
similar resolution to both phrases a
rhythm of eight notes a square and even
rhythm the structural use of the phrase
as an ostinato the timbre of the
instrumentation and the notably empty
and sparse texture of the compositions
the thing is none of these things by
themselves are copyrightable and even
when you use all of them together it
doesn't turn an otherwise non
copyrightable thing into a copyrightable
phrase if the sheet music isn't
copyrightable you can't get protection
by playing that same thing on a
synthesizer it's theoretically possible
to get a copyright over the selection of
unprotected elements but you have to
show a ton of creativity and more than
what flame has alleged here it would be
much easier to do if he was claiming
that the entire song violated the
copyright rather than just this really
small part that is otherwise similar now
the court went on to note that even if
the ostinato was creative enough to be
considered protectable under copyright
it wasn't substantially similar to the
Dark Horse ostinato in other words there
was no actionable copying or copyright
infringement a selection of a song is
only infringed if the two works
substantially share the same combination
of protectable elements and remember the
actual notes themselves in this case
were not protectable and this is where
Led Zeppelin saved Katy Perry yes
seriously see in this case the
protectable elements would be so narrow
that a combination of protectable
elements between the two songs would
need to be virtually identical and the
court held that flame was unable to
satisfy this test for a substantial
similarity in making this decision the
judge referred to another huge copyright
case that the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals decided just a couple
weeks ago there the Ninth Circuit upheld
a 2016 decision that Led Zeppelin's
Stairway to Heaven did not infringe on
the band's spirits 1968 instrumental
track torus now these two songs are much
much closer than Dark Horse and joyful
noise here's Led Zeppelin's unbelievably
famous intro to stairway to heaven
[Music]
and here's Tauruses song spirit
[Music]
now to my ear those songs and we're here
we're talking about the whole songs in
general sound much much more similar
than Dark Horse does to joyful noise and
the Ninth Circuit agreed it held we have
never extended copyright protection to
just a few notes instead we have held
that a four note sequence common in the
music field is not the copyrightable
expression in a song and in Led Zeppelin
in order to prove copyright infringement
the two works at issue would need to be
virtually identical the court found that
stairway to heaven in spirit were not
virtually identical just as the Court
did in Katy Perry
now the Led Zeppelin case had mainly to
do with whether a defendant's access to
a song can be used to prove copyright
infringement or plagiarism the Ninth
Circuit actually reversed a precedent
called the inverse ratio rule that had
lasted for forty five years and this is
an issue I have actually litigated and
that particular rule deserved to die see
the inverse ratio rule meant that the
more access that was shown between the
alleged copyright infringer and the
original copyrighted work the less
substantial similarity was required to
establish infringement that enabled
plaintiffs to allege copying if they
could show that the defendant had likely
heard the song and between Led Zeppelin
and tourists well they toured together
in the 60s so there was almost no doubt
that Jimmy Page had heard Tauruses song
but the thing is that probably shouldn't
matter just because someone might have
heard or had access to a song or other
creative work doesn't mean that we
should change the standard required to
show that two things are similar the
more access doesn't mean the less
similarity that you have to prove that
unfairly burdened songs that simply got
a lot of radio airtime the music
industry has actually been critical of
this rule for decades especially since
it was not used by courts outside of the
Ninth Circuit one reason the music
industry hated this rule was because
access was so much easier to prove in
the age of digital streaming everyone
pretty much has access to any other
songs and in fact Adam Neely did another
video talking about a group of people
who tried to copyright every conceivable
melody that could possibly exist in the
world and they sort of recognize though
that not everyone has access to this
hard drive of songs that they created so
not actually solve the the issue that
they're dealing with definitely check
out that video but after the Led
Zeppelin decision to the extent that the
inverse ratio rule ever existed which is
sort of an open question at least in the
Ninth Circuit that rule has been
completely abolished and as in the Led
Zeppelin case with Katy Perry when you
filter out the unprotected elements of
the songs at issue there just isn't much
left and there certainly isn't enough to
justify copyright infringement
now those astute legal eagles out there
probably wondering how come this case
turned out different than the Marvin
Gaye blurred lines case well that is a
really interesting quirk of procedural
law because Katy Perry also lost a jury
verdict but then was able to overturn it
what happened with Robin Thicke and
blurred lines
well now it's of course possible that
Katy Perry may in fact lose her case on
appeal but I think that's probably
really unlikely copyright issues are
complicated and they're often decided as
a matter of law by the court factual
disputes such as who is lying and who is
telling the truth are decided by a jury
but issues of law can be decided by a
judge and generally if you can you want
your case to be decided by a judge
quickly before it gets to a jury because
a jury can do anything who knows now in
certain cases you can ask the judge to
decide in your favor as a matter of law
before it gets to trial here Katy
Perry's lawyers made a motion for
judgment as a matter of law before it
got to the jury the judge denied the
motion and the case went to trial where
the jury found in favor of flame and
awarded him 2.8 million dollars but
under the Federal Rules of Civil
Procedure rule 50 if you made a motion
before the trial then you can make a
renewed motion afterwards but you have
to make that initial motion and that's
what happened here Katy Perry made the
motion it was denied the Led Zeppelin
case came out in the interim they
refiled after the jury verdict and then
the judge looking at the Led Zeppelin
case said okay this is on point and
decided in Katy Perry's favor and
basically overturned the decision of the
jury court basically said no reasonable
jury could have found in favor of the
plaintiff which is funny because all 12
jurors didn't find in favor for the
plaintiff but that's neither here nor
there now if a party fails to make a
rule 50 motion at the close
evidence that party waives its right to
challenge the sufficiency of the
evidence of the verdict later on this
can be a very serious mistake
and to prove that all you have to do is
ask Robin Thicke and Pharrell 'z lawyers
because they did not make a rule 50
motion for judgment as a matter of law
and so after the jury found against them
for millions of dollars they weren't
able to make a renewed motion afterwards
and it's entirely possible that had they
done that the court would have sided
with them because a lot of people a lot
of musicologists believe that the
blurred lines lawsuit was incorrectly
decided so the bottom line is that
copyright law is complicated and it's
hard
both the Led Zeppelin and Katy Perry
decisions are examples of courts pushing
back against the blurred lines verdict
and I think it's gonna be a lot harder
to prove copyright infringement in the
Ninth Circuit if for better or worse
people borrow from predecessors works
and create new ones especially in the
music world and we all share this common
vocabulary but at the end of the day not
all copying is copyright infringement
just like not everything the glitters is
gold now whether you're on the sign of
Katy Perry or flame you can see how both
of them use similar building blocks to
make their world-famous songs because
making music is actually surprisingly
easy if for any reason you're spending
some extra time at home and want to
learn how to make your own music I
highly recommend Mike Boyd Skillshare
class guitar fundamentals learn quick
with Mike Boyd in this class Mike Boyd
walks you through the basics of learning
to play the guitar starting simply with
the anatomy of the guitar and leading
all the way up to playing your first two
songs honestly you probably don't even
need much of a lesson to be able to play
the ostinato from dark horse but even if
you've never picked up a guitar in your
life learn quicks Mike Boyd will show
you what you need to know it's a great
way to learn a new skill or if you want
to learn another skill you can check out
Mike's other skill shared class how to
learn strategies for starting practicing
and mastering the skills you've always
wanted which helps anyone learn
something new reduce their likelihood of
quitting the new Challenger get good at
something faster and now is a great time
for people to stave off boredom by
learning new skills Skillshare is an
online learning community that has
of thousands of classes on everything
like music design technology and
business it's great for anyone that
wants to learn a new skill like learning
a star or other musical instruments a
yearly membership is less than $10 per
month but the first 1,000 legal eagles
will get to three months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below plus it
really helps out this channel so just
click on the link in the description the
free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must know topics so
you can improve your skills and learn
new things all free for two months so
improve yourself now while you finally
have the time do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here where I talk about all kinds
of copyright related things so click on
this playlist and I'll see you in court